take the load off Fanny that's the focus
of tonight's
angle oh how the mighty have fallen
remember the media was instantly a
struck by The Fulton County DA she was a
woman on a mission after she announced
her indictment of President Trump on the
state racketeering charges in August the
New York Times they described her as a
force to be reckoned with Fanny T Willis
strowed up to the podium in a red dress
last year in downtown Atlanta flanked by
an array of of dark suits and
stone-faced officers in uniform her
voice rang out loud and clear with a
hint of swagger is bad writing and the
liberal cable host they were busy
setting the narrative as well a smart
gutsy female African-American prosecutor
versus a reckless dangerous former
president they thought they'd found
their Trump Slayer oh my God like she
blew me away and I think about this
whole part of the future of Donald Trump
as a former president differently now I
know funny Willis said the other night
that she was prepared to try the case
within six months and I'm sure she is
she has been investigating this case for
two and a half years Oliver Ducks will
be in a
row and that's not all she had lined up
reports show that she had her boyfriend
Nathan Wade lined up to get paid a nice
sum for doing her dirty work she even
sent him to the White House to check in
with Biden's staff billing Fulton County
$2,000 on two different occasions in
2022 for his mystery work Wade was an
interesting choice even the Washington
Post conceded and they noted that he had
scant experience in Prosecuting any
cases but when allegations of corruption
about overpaying her unqualified
boyfriend started trickling in Fanny did
what most left leftists have been
trained to do play the victim and cry
racism I appointed three special counsel
is is my right to do paid them all the
same hourly rate they only attacked one
I hired one black man another Superstar
a great
friend and a great lawyer oh Lord they
going to be mad when I call them out on
this
nonsense first thing they
say oh she going to play the race card
now but no God isn't it them who's
playing the race card when they only
question
one but Fanny's a fantastic liar because
her lover was paid $100 more an hour
than others who are far more experienced
to be precise records show that he was
paid $100 more an hour than the
experienced Rico prosecutor John Floyd
according to documents obtained by The
Daily Caller
Foundation but facts don't bother Fanny
she needs divine intervention why are
they so surprised that a diverse team
that I I assembled your child can
accomplish extraordinary things God
wasn't it them that attacked this lawyer
of impeccable credentials the black man
I chose has been a judge more than 10
years I'm just asking
God is it that some will never see a
black man as qualified no matter his
achievements yet as we saw with
Harvard's claudi and gay these racial
victim ploes are kind of losing their
currency
even The Daily Beast knows that fanny
has caused a major headache because if
she G A got a lefty a hefty salary for a
romantic partner that's a genuine
conflict of interest that would require
her
dismissal and even Fanny's buds at CNN
can help her everyone that we've spoken
to they agree that the Optics in this
are just horrible in fact there's some
now highlevel Democrats in this state
who are calling fonny Willis to step
down and accused herself from this case
now once again this reminds us how
corrupt the corporate media are because
just a few years ago Time Magazine was
lauding Fanny Willis as one of those
boss ladies who is small in stature but
big in presence a commander armed get
this with high
standards now Democrats have made a big
mistake here instead of trying to win
the presidency by advancing policies
that actually improve lives they decided
to try to destroy America and Destroy
Donald Trump Biden flunkies are flooding
our border with migrants and drowning
Trump with endless legal attacks waged
by vicious corrupt climbers people like
Fanny Willis but hyper polii and
entitled prosecutors like her they're
kind of a dime a doesn't these days and
they're disliked by hardworking
Americans who just want someone who will
call balls and Strikes and as president
Trump continues to Barnstorm the country
on his way to securing the GOP
nomination
Fanny will be prepping for her
deposition in a week in the her paramor
divorce case attorneys for Joselyn Wade
Nathan's wife successfully subpoenaed
the da so how's Fanny going to get out
of this Jam claim Mrs Wade's a racist
too well it's time to take the load off
Fanny and shut down this tainted
prosecution hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else